we start with another edition of Jerry
Nadler clown show on Capitol Hill well
today again another circus in case you
haven't heard
nathless judiciary committee has started
official impeachment proceeding it's
against President Trump for what high
crime misdemeanors nobody knows not even
he knows it's all one big political
stunt surrounding what is nothing short
of a psychotic rage hatred that is never
ending it's every second of every day
now the simple truth is there are no
high crimes there are no misdemeanors
there was no collusion no conspiracy no
obstruction but Jerry's psycho well dog
and pony show must go on
the weak lethargic Judiciary Chairman he
needs to appease the radical extreme
base of this new Democratic Party and if
that means destroying the careers of his
colleagues every other House member a
more moderate districts and districts
that Donald Trump won he could care less
if it hurts the country sadly he could
key care even less than that
like speaker name only Nancy Pelosi
Nadler is terrified of the squad and all
the other extreme socialists that are
now steering the ship of this new
extreme radical Democratic Socialist
Party and today Nadler well he hauled
former Trump campaign manager Corey
Lewandowski before the committee Corey
Lewandowski has already testified before
the House Intelligence Committee not
once but twice and the Senate Intel
committee for eight hours and he was
interviewed by Special Counsel Muller's
which hunt team for over 15 hours so
Gerry what was the point of today's
testimony clearly today was not a
fact-finding mission it was a political
grandstanding opportunity by a group of
inept angry Democrats people that don't
care about we the people you the
American people they're not fighting for
jobs and not fighting for a safer world
and not fighting for more security in
this country no what they're fighting
for about the real issues facing America
Donald Trump impeaching them for no
reason
take a look the White House is
obstruction of Congress ranges across
nearly every committee and virtually
every investigation of these
raishin we had mr. Mahler here had a
long day of it judging by all accounts
it didn't go real oil
this has been more obstruction of
Congress by this administration and
you've followed their instructions and
you're doing just exactly what they
thought you'd do you're a loyal soldier
the president is falsely accused of
colluding with a foreign state to impact
the election Jim Comey when we deposed
him at that very table said after ten
months of investigation we didn't have a
thing Bob Mulligan's name Special
Counsel he wastes thirty million dollars
of taxpayer money twenty two month
investigation he sets at that table just
a few weeks ago and gives the same darn
answer but these guys over here they
don't care be here to be telling the
truth
I yield back the time of the gentlelady
has expired the witness may answer the
question I don't believe there was a
question congressman very well yes it
was chairman Adler chairman of the clown
show on Capitol Hill if you're listening
tonight and I'm sure you'll hear about
it you should know that the Democratic
members on your committee they pretty
much looked as dumb and stupid as you do
every day today members of your
committee well they were humiliated they
were embarrassed Corey Lewandowski owned
them take a look again congressman I
recognize that the privilege is not mine
but I've been asked by the White House
to understand I'd be happy to answer
your question or you can have a
conversation by yourself but if you like
to ask me a question I'll be happy I'm
just going to continue the reason is
don't ask me a question in my time this
is a house judiciary not a house party
are you the hit man the bag man the
lookout or all of the above I think I'm
the good looking man actually are you
ashamed of the words that you wrote down
presidents wall well I'm very happy of
what I've written but you're welcome to
read if you'd like that's pretty amazing
now this so-called proceeding nothing
but a joke your impeachment fantasy yes
to all the Democrats on the committee
it's over it's never gonna happen and
what you're doing is you're showing the
American people who you really are
American people see this charade for
what it is but by all means my advice
keep going don't give up keep giving
this all of your obsessive compulsive
rage don't always give in to the
temptation it's Donald Trump impeachment
24/7 because I'm sure the president's
campaign they will thank you after 2020s
November election